meine damen meine herren die runde von
bund und ländern hat jetzt anfang
dezember beschlossen dass der teil
lockdown bis in den januar fortgesetzt
wird der bayerische ministerpräsident
spricht bereits von verschärfungen die
im januar notwendig sein könnten der
kanzleramtschef hat gesprochen über den
märz all das zeigt die bundesregierung
das kanzleramt hat keine langfristig
tragbare strategie es ist den menschen
das ist dem land nicht mehr zuzumuten
das scheibchenweise mit einer
salamitaktik den menschen gesagt wird
was sie zu erwarten haben
wir fordern das kanzleramt auf endlich
zu einer dauerhaften langfristig durch
haltbaren strategie für unser land zu
kommen
im zentrum muss es stehen die wirklich
bedrohten menschen zu schützen
diejenigen die wirklich einen schweren
krankheitsverlauf befürchten müssten
es ist für uns alarmierend dass die zahl
von infektionen in alten- und
pflegeeinrichtungen stark steigt dass
ältere menschen menschen mit
vorerkrankungen stärker jetzt im
krankenhaus und intensivmedizinischen
bereich zu finden sind
es gibt verklagen aus dem bereich der
altenpflege das schutzausrüstung und
tests nicht hinreichende zahl zur
verfügung stehen
dort muss nun nachgearbeitet werden wir
wünschen uns eine krisenstrategie die
endlich die großen defizite beim schutz
der wirklich gefährdeten menschen
beseitigt stadt scheibchenweise nach
salamitaktik immer neue einschränkungen
immer neue verlängerungen anzukündigen
so werden wir die nächsten wochen die
nächsten monate gemeinsam nicht bestehen
können zerstören ist dass die hilfen für
die betriebe die auf behördliche
anordnung geschlossen sind nicht sicher
ausgezahlt werden
die november hilfen sind auch im
dezember noch nicht geflossen
da wird schon insbesondere aus der union
infrage gestellt wie denn die
kompensation im januar februar und
darüber hinaus sein soll
das verschärft die existenznöte die
existenzsorgen bei vielen millionen
menschen
hier ist die regierung hier ist der
wirtschaftsminister aufgefordert ganz
schnell klarheit zu schaffen
wenn ein betrieb wegen politischer
entscheidungen geschlossen wird nicht
geöffnet werden kann
dann muss es eine entschädigung geben
die muss schnell und unbürokratisch
schließen weil wir sonst die akzeptanz
für die eindämmung der pandemie für die
korona politik insgesamt verlieren
würden uns überzeugt nicht dass im
dezember immer noch nicht die november
hilfe ausgezahlt ist es in den sternen
steht ob es in diesem jahr überhaupt
noch eine angemessene unterstützung gibt
so werden viele viele tausend betriebe
aus dem mittelständischen bereich in die
zahlungsunfähigkeit getrieben da gehen
arbeitsplätze und existenzen verloren
die wir so schnell nicht zurück bekämen